[Music]
thank you
welcome to the data science hangout so
nice to see you all hope everybody's
having a great week beautiful here in
Boston today I think it's about 70
degrees but I'm Rachel Dempsey I lead
our Pro community at posit and the data
science hangout is our open space to
chat about data Science Leadership
questions you're facing and getting to
hear what's going on in the world of
data across different Industries
and so it happens every Thursday pretty
much every single Thursday unless it's a
holiday or at the same time same place
so if you're watching this recording at
some point later on YouTube you can add
it to your calendar details below but
every week we feature a different data
science leader as my co-host to help
lead our discussion and answer questions
from you all
so together we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment for
everyone we love hearing from everybody
no matter your level of experience or
area of work
so it is totally okay to just listen in
if you want but there's also three ways
you can jump in and ask questions or
provide your own perspective on certain
topics so you can jump in by raising
your hand on Zoom you can put questions
in the zoom chat and just put a little
star next to it if you want me to read
it out instead
and then we also have a slido link where
you can ask questions anonymously
and I think Curtis you can grab that
slide a link and share it in the chat
but I'm so excited to have Natalie
joining us here today Natalie O'Shea is
an analytics consultant at better up and
Natalie I'd love to start with having
you introduce yourself introducing
yourself and maybe share a little bit
about your work and something you like
to do outside of work too
sure yeah so as Rachel said I'm I'm
Natalie
um yeah I'm an analytics consultant at
better up
um and a lot of the work that I'm doing
right now
um is focused actually on building uh
flexible scalable reporting system in
shiny and I'm like fresh on that right
now because I just finished recording my
posit conference talk so
um hopefully maybe going to share some
of those learnings there
um yeah well I could go on and on I have
a very uh long and winding road to where
I ended up so lots of diversions and
different experiences
um but yeah outside of work
um well I've got my drum kit here I have
not been practicing as much as I should
but that's kind of a hobby of mine
trying to learn how to drum as an adult
I never learned a musical instrument
when I was growing up and then I saw one
of my favorite bands at a jazz club and
I was like all right I need to learn
strum so I'm a very bad drummer
um I will also say my birthday was
yesterday or the day before and now I'm
forgetting but happy birthday oh thank
you I'm bringing it up because a new
hobby no not quite a hobby but I got to
meet beluga whales at the Shedd Aquarium
and that was pretty pretty awesome so
now I'm like wanting to become a whale
trainer as well on the side we'll see
about that
I love it that's awesome well you said
your favorite band who's your favorite
band
it's a band called lettuce
um yeah they're like a a jazz funk
hip-hop band they're very fun cool
so
while we wait for questions to come in
from everyone I thought it'd be helpful
to kind of put ourselves in the mindset
of some of the work that you do at
better up would you be able to share
maybe a few youth or a use case that
comes to mind for your data team
yeah so
um the whole kind of approach I'm
building right now
um you know it's a big I'm a consultant
though I'm not really directly
Consulting as much right now I'm kind of
supporting a lot of our Consultants but
as consultants they need to be able to
kind of customize reports and
presentations for partners so
um I built out a system within shiny
um to actually populate slide decks with
metrics and visualizations and I can go
on and on about the reasons why I took
that approach but
um a big reason why I wanted to have all
of that kind of populate in Google slide
decks was
um so that you know we can customize the
look and feel and the story
um of Any Given company's data
specifically tailored to them
um and so yeah I can go on and on about
like why I chose that approach over
something like parameterized reporting
which I'm also a big fan of
but yeah that's that's kind of a big big
project of mine right now and then in
addition to that we know each other
because I've been leading in a pretty
major uh procurement effort and we're in
the final stages now of like installing
posit software so we're really excited
about that but I learned a lot about
what it takes to kind of build a
business case for data science tooling
at your organization
um and getting buy-in across the org and
it's you know it's a pretty major lift
to get get something like that off the
ground
what was one of the biggest Lessons
Learned in building business case
um I would say
like one of the biggest Lessons Learned
in building the business case was have
kind of a flagship project that ties to
um Direct business value so the project
that I'm doing really helps automate a
lot of our processes and makes it a lot
faster and easier and more
uh streamlined to populate these decks
with with different Data Insights
um and so that was enough of a driver
kind of showcasing
um the additional flexibility that open
source programming tools offer us over a
more business intelligence tool that was
really
um a big driver in what led us to get
get this this software so I'd say having
kind of a project that you can directly
tie to business value
um that's like a big big learning from
it and then I'd say another learning
from it I would never have been able to
get this pushed through if I didn't have
a supportive manager who really walked
me through the whole process and helped
me navigate a lot of the organizational
hierarchy to get something like this off
the ground so kind of finding and
developing your community of allies that
are also interested in the same thing as
you
um you're you're definitely not going to
be able to do this alone
well thank you so much for that that's
that's really helpful and your data team
at better up I think is of R and python
users is that right yes yeah
and are they are they going to use this
uh environment too
yes yeah so we're I've really
um sorry my dog is like chewing up my
plants but what's your dog's name name's
Gino
um if anybody here is a Pittsburgh
Penguins fan that's that's where the
name is coming from
um yes okay yeah so our python users
um so I've been really focused on
developing our our community at better
up
um and we've made some big strides in
that
um the python user Community tends to be
I'd say more focused on machine learning
use cases so I've had some uh
interactions with them and I'm using
python right now in my project
um but we're definitely uh I'd say the
our user Community is a little more
vibrant I think I'm not here to start
the like our first Pokemon debate but I
do find that I think our users are just
like kind of tend to be more quirky and
like really excited about are and python
users are like this is the tool to get
the job done and it python is a great
tool to get the job done but I'm just
such a fan of our our community but one
of the ways in which I kind of reached
out to our python Community when we were
going through this procurement process
was actually
um you know challenging myself to learn
how to use vetiver for ML Ops and doing
that all within vs code and quarto so
that I could kind of showcase hey this
isn't just a tool for our users this
really is a tool for python users as
well this is how it could be implemented
in your own workflow obviously with the
caveat that I am by no means a machine
learning expert so
um but kind of taking the time to
showcase the capabilities in their tools
and language of choice
um yeah I'd say that was also kind of a
big learning from this this effort
that's really valuable thank you I just
put the link to the vetiver package in
there if people hadn't heard of it
before too
I see tatsu's calling me out and saying
it's not that nice in Boston I would say
like 65 is close enough to 70 at 3 P.M
it's gonna be that nice maybe not right
this second cloudy it is cloudy and it's
wet racial I'm thinking of like the time
where I get to get outside a little bit
later that it's going to be nicer that's
fair enough there's potential
so it is sure I see you asked a question
in the chat with a little star
um it's a little
for me to read no problem do you want to
read it yeah absolutely okay
yeah uh hey everyone I'm a data
scientist working with Nissan uh blister
Franklin Tennessee
um yeah it's great to know about Natalie
thank you so much for sharing your
experience and uh insight about that I
have been working on the same near
similar environments like
um I have been developing a few other
finding applications and then I have
deployed into our production server that
is our studio connect but a lot of time
there have been circumstances that when
I have deployed the application it it
perfectly runs fine in my local
environment and then when it is
published they're like in the server
um it gives issues not so frequently but
kind of once in a while right maybe once
a month or two or three uh something
like that so and we had to connect raise
the ticket or contact the admins and
take that help to resolve this two and
then they take a couple of days and you
know meanwhile we had to communicate to
the business and hey you know the app is
not running uh you know apologize so uh
give us a couple of days those kind of
issues so have you worked in the
situations ever and then how did you
like any efforts you have taken to make
the work seamless or non-disturbing from
the business standpoint
yeah that is a great question and I wish
I had one of my collaborators here harsh
who is on our data Ops Team
um and so another learning again in that
in the vein of like building a community
of allies that support you in this work
I'm very lucky to have someone who's
really focused on the installation and
deployment side of things
um right now we're actually working
through that exact issue
um so I'm kind of bouncing around here
but I'm a huge proponent or I really
love the Rhino framework for shiny I
don't know if you've encountered that at
all but one of the nice things about it
is that you use RN for package
management and so there's a lock file
right with all of your package sources
so we've been working through some
issues with that right now because we we
did get the full posit team Suite of
project products so now we're just
having to make sure that the lock file
is reading from
a package manager instead of like a
binary source so I'm a little out of my
depth in terms of like all the specifics
with uh deployment but we're we're
definitely in the stages right now so we
just finished installing
um posit and workbench and we are uh
trying to deploy the app at the moment
but we haven't quite finished it out
because in addition to like our
environment package management stuff
that we're working with there's also the
python aspect of the app
um and so making sure that we have our
you know whether it's a conda
environment or some sort of pip
environment something for the python
environment so yeah we're just ironing
out some of those deployment issues but
definitely a very common problem I would
say
I I can't quite speak to all of the like
technical aspects of that deployment but
on the more human side of things
um one approach that we've taken with
how we're deploying this app out to our
organization is starting with like our
more internal team and that kind of
slowly ramping it out so that we don't
just open the floodgates to everyone
um and then are kind of like you know
putting out fires but
um taking a more slow approach so that
people know hey you know we're in the
early stages of deploying this we're
still ironing Out The Kinks
um I do know that our our data Ops
Engineers really focused on making sure
that we employ like infrastructure as
code approach to how we're deploying
things so anywhere and everywhere that
we can kind of like codify things in
kubernetes we are
um so there's yeah there's just a lot of
moving parts to deploying an app to
production even if it's not you know
partner facing production but just
internal use and
um I think one of the big
most important things about deploying a
shiny app like this is you want people
to trust it so
um I think taking the time and really
building in some buffer
um so that you know that the app is
going to be load tested and reliable all
of these things before it goes out to
people
um is a good good practice so that you
don't deteriorate trust in your data
products
yeah absolutely I agree and then you
know I'm quite friendly our team
um like from the developer standpoint
like from data scientists and data
analysts standpoint we kind of Whenever
there were some issues in the
applications we have directly
um reached out to admin and you know he
handles from the package managers
standpoint and then from the maintenance
standpoint in the production
um but yeah I think that's good
suggestions I should probably discuss
with him sometime and then you know get
the proper practice managers or maybe
Rhino that you included
um yeah I see uh I see Catherine you had
some thoughts on this topic too in a
chat and sorry if I'm putting you on the
spot here no that's okay
um just mentioning you know we we use
the posit products and get back
deployment so with from our Version
Control repository
um my team kind of has a workflow where
we
do like a Dev deployment so we have our
Master deployment and that kind of sits
there and we also have a get back
deployment from our developed Branch so
any changes that we make can be tested
there vetted out before it goes to the
version of the app that our customers
are using
um and so that can kind of troubleshoot
some of those some of those issues where
it's like oh you know I forgot I
installed the dev version of a package
on my local thing trying to get this new
feature
um but you didn't fix your manifest
before it goes to the deployment and so
that would break and you can find that
out from your Dev deployments before it
ever gets to that customer interaction
interruption yeah and a lot of time
funny but not funny thing is that
um it we perfectly test in the dev and
then application is running for about
two weeks a month or so and then like
all of a sudden like it crashes in
production like it's trusted and then
business like literally we make Habit to
the you know and and consumers that they
can wake up in the morning and first
thing they open are they open up is the
application report report and then all
of a sudden like 10 emails and 10 emails
coming in into the inbox page where it's
not working
um so those kind of things so yeah I
mean great inverse thank you yeah okay
plus what Catherine said having that
deployment environment and then again
I'm just like gonna keep pushing the
Rhino framework I think it's fantastic
there's also some really good
um continuous integration features with
that so that
um when you do you know merge your
development Branch into Maine
um you're having some really good tests
being done to make sure that it can run
on various environments so that's part
of the continuous integration is a test
that like does this run on Mac does this
run on Linux does it work on Windows um
and as long as all those tests are
passing it's not a guarantee that there
won't ever be something that comes in
and kind of brings it all down but um
you know building it as many fail safes
as possible is always a good good
practice
is definitely a new territory I think
for many many data scientists
I wanted to make sure to get over to
some of the anonymous questions too and
just remind people you can ask questions
over there on slido as well if we want
to reshare in the chat here but one
question was what advice do you have for
Consulting work and they said I had a
brief experience last year and it was
tough because of their data quality
issues
yeah
data quality that is like the hill that
I will die on constantly like I I find
myself always making the case that like
I know we want to build these complex
machine learning models or this or that
but like first and foremost data quality
and I'm excited for your your talk next
week because I know uh one of my like
our heroes is Emily Ryder reader I'm not
sure how to pronounce her last name but
she's such an inspiration for like
things like grouped data checks
um so I think I like living at that that
intersection between data engineering
and data science and trying to kind of
make sure we have reliable data
pipelines haven't yet gone into DBT but
that's definitely
um something on the on the agenda but um
any yeah data oh with Consulting so data
quality and Consulting
um yeah that is uh that is a constant
struggle
um I think
um I think I really do take my role I
I'm again I'm not as much external
Consulting but I consult internally with
our team so kind of setting expectations
of what is possible given our current
data architecture
um and data quality and working closely
with like our analytics Engineers to get
those data quality tests built in that
match
um the level of granularity that you're
trying to work with
um but yeah that is that's a constant uh
uh issue I feel like there was something
else I was going to respond to with that
and now I'm completely blanking on what
what it was that I was going to address
in terms of the console team maybe I'll
remember you can tell us when it comes
back to you yeah it'll just be like one
of those light bulb moments being oh
that was it
Travis I see you had a question in the
chat do you want to jump in
sure hey
um curious about the the sometimes
boring side of cloud infrastructure our
admin
um we're kind of struggling with this a
little bit right now
um thinking about you know we're going
to be hiring a cloud architect soon and
we want that person obviously land posit
products wherever we go I don't know
anything about kubernetes I'm glad other
people do
um what does that look like for you well
do you have a separate team that kind of
runs that show
how often do you interact with them like
what's that look like um did you work
with the full these so-called um full
service providers to kind of get the
stuff set up um any any tips there are
welcome thanks yeah for sure yeah the
same boat
um and the thank God for for like the
data Engineers that do love the
kubernetes stuff I'm like that's great
and so glad you like that that's that's
not the world that I want to live in but
I I recognize its importance
um I will plug one of the things that we
did to make sure that we were getting
off on the right foot with all of our
posit products was we we got I think
three months of three or six months I
forget of technical account management
support so we have weekly Tam meetings
um and that's kind of where we surface a
lot of like these issues so if we're
having trouble with the particular
deployment or we're running into package
installation issues and we're not sure
like how to address them um our Tam
support team is really helpful in making
sure we get that all set up
um I again I feel super fortunate
um again to the point of like build your
group of allies and like and make a you
know you're you're gonna need a
community around you to build this stuff
out and we were very lucky to get the
support of our data Ops Team
um so always uh you know we're we're in
an interesting stage in our business
right now because we are a startup and
you know we've had you know kind of more
quick startupy processes and we're at
that stage in development where we're
really trying to again take an
infrastructure as code approach with how
we build out stuff
um so we're our data Ops Squad is pretty
new
um but I'm a I'm an anthropologist by
training so I'm all about relationships
so build those relationships with uh
with your data Engineers
um and those kind of folks that do this
um in our organization I know not every
organization does this but once a
quarter our our product team does uh
make-a-thon
um and this is just an an opportunity
for us to you know team up with other
people put whatever crazy idea you have
out there
um and then start to build some of those
cross-functional relationships so one of
the makeathons that we did in the past
and our team
um I propose like okay we need to start
to document and build out some best
practices on custom application
development and that was how I actually
built the bridge between our team and
our data Ops Team because I knew I got
to reach out to our data Ops Team like
they can help us kind of Define some of
these best practices
um and so yeah I look for like little
informal fun opportunities to build
those relationships because that
makeathon then was what got us that
support for getting the support for
installation of the products because
I'm not a Linux admin I could not you
wouldn't want me to set up these
products so having someone who's
enthusiastic about that makes all the
difference and
um it's really great because uh I think
when you develop that relationship you
can also really make it clear what your
needs are so one of uh the big needs on
our team was simply you know we work
from a snowflake database
getting that connection set up has
always been a pain for people and that
was one of the pro reasons why we wanted
to get workbench and so uh now we have a
close relationship with our data Ops
Team they understand like all of the
intricacies of why it's hard for us to
connect to the database or the the
connection isn't stable or like it
varies across different machines
um and so our our Engineers currently
working on like a very streamlined
process so that people don't ever have
to think about
setting up their database connection
they can just log in Via SSO and then
get into workbench and that's all done
for them so
um yeah I'm not that person but I I
think I I do a decent job of like
finding those people and making sure
that they know that you know we
appreciate their work and we need it
desperately
that's awesome Rachel will you allow me
a follow-up question
of course okay
um yeah well actually first that's good
info about the Tam because we just had a
kickoff with posits Tam group and it
seems like it'll be really helpful so
glad to hear that it worked well for you
we'll pursue that as well but yeah the
workbench I'm intrigued by this so I saw
Hadley posting something recently about
um like vs code and workbench like
what's y'all's experience with workbench
so far like I didn't know it did all
that stuff and in particular I'm very
curious about copilot in vs code I know
that's not going to be something that's
in the rcd like products natively
um for good reasons but is that
something y'all are doing workbench so
far so good
well I don't know about all the co-pilot
stuff so maybe someone from Project
couldn't talk to that but
um yeah that was like kind of how I sold
sold posit products internally because I
think you know I'm such a fan of the new
brand renamed to pause it because I
think previously it was really hard to
make a case for an RN python approach to
data science with our studio formerly
known as our studio products because
everyone assumed that that was all you
could do
um but like I mentioned earlier when I
was kind of going around trying to make
the business case for these these this
tooling
um I I was like okay I know that a lot
of our our python users use vs code and
python so like I need to show them what
a piece of their work would look like in
Python and vs code on this platform to
kind of you know fully convince them
that it's not just theoretical that yes
you can spin up a vs code instance but
like show them yeah here's me a little
old me that doesn't ever work in vs code
or python
um not ever but rarely
um spinning up you know machine learning
Ops kind of system in in those products
so yeah we're we're definitely using
that we haven't really deployed a
workbench out to like the broader team
yet because again taking that approach
of like Iron Out The Kinks first before
you open it up to a broader group of
people so myself and one of my
colleagues are kind of working with our
data Ops Team to make sure that it's a
really good experience once we do open
the gates for the rest of our
organization
um and making sure that our python users
are able to use their tools of choice as
well as a big part of that
with awesome thanks
thank you
so something that I wanted to ask you
about is I know leading up this we were
talking a little bit about like
developing communities of belonging and
one of the communities you're a part of
is data science by Design and just want
to make sure we chatted a little bit
about that too
oh my God yeah I could talk forever
about this community
um so I I like hesitate I'm technically
on the leadership uh committee for data
science by Design
um which was like such an honor to be a
part of that I've been doing that since
their first uh meeting last what was
that summer of 2021
the pandemic years all blur together for
me but
um yeah like this community is just like
small But Mighty
um we have a lot of so I come from kind
of a or an organizing background as well
um so doing a lot of community
organizing and we have a lot of people
in the community organizing World there
and a lot of us are big fans of Adrian
Marie Brown and we've kind of talked
about who wrote a book that for me was
like life-changing called emergent
strategy
um and we've really have taken the
approach with this community to focus on
um she calls it in an emergent strategy
uh a mile an inch wide mile deep
organizing strategy something along
those lines which is essentially just
like prioritizing quality and deep
relationships and like a Vibrant
Community over the breadth and the
largeness of the community so I think
that approach has been amazing so
um yeah it's it's such a great group
we've really
um we do a lot of like creative coding
stuff a lot of the people in our
community actually
um ijamaka and Sharla are going to be
doing a workshop on I think it was at
posit like bringing out your inner
artist or something like that so we've
got a lot of people that are really
interested in the intersections between
art design data science Community
organizing like it's quite an
interesting mix of people but it all
kind of ties together somehow
um could not recommend that group more
we actually have an anthology coming out
pretty soon here we released an
anthology last uh last year
um that was what was the title of it
um now I'm forgetting because I'm so
focused on this new Anthology but the
new Anthology is our our environment so
we're really talking about environments
broadly defined
um a lot of environmental data
scientists submitted work there but we
also have you know topics on things like
community building your your local
environment things like that so yeah I I
don't even know quite where to start
with that Community but
um again where when when you find like a
group of people that's just so
supportive I think you know entering the
data science field can be so
overwhelming because there's so many
facets to it and things that you feel
like you need to be an expert in
um and you don't like everyone has their
own expertise everyone has their own
lived experience that they bring to the
table that is really important for how
we build out things
um so I often find that it's not the
most technical person in the room that
has the best ideas it's the person with
like the most direct experience with the
problem that you're trying to solve so
um yeah that's a long-winded approach to
say that I absolutely love the that that
community and very proud to be kind of
part of it
that's wonderful
I see a lot of uh
comments here on community two in the
chat and Alan I think you just asked a
question here I can't read it all right
now but you want to jump in
yeah maybe I wrote I wrote too much and
I I uh well no I just meant I couldn't
like see it that quickly and then know
if there was a question but I think it's
in there yeah there is there is a
question there eventually
um I think this is probably applicable
Beyond workbench but my my
um thinking about it Natalie started
when you were talking about the sort of
gradual expansion of that as a tool to a
broader audience and what I'm
experiencing a lot right now is tension
between like portfolio simplification of
tools versus autonomy
and I wonder what that conversation was
like uh for you and your team to
consider like what should the scope of
something like this be and what are the
various trade-offs of trying to make it
like broadly useful maybe being better
supported but having a steeper Hill to
climb versus being autonomous but maybe
less well supported and and what those
what those conversations were like
yeah so I think
um you know we we use like looker a lot
internally as our business intelligence
tool so I feel like that's kind of where
like a lot of our efforts right as an
analytics team have been like devoted to
that but I you know as great as looker
is in its many ways like there are
always questions that you're not going
to be able to answer with the business
intelligence tool so we've always had
people working in R and Python and doing
their own analyzes so we you know I
think a big part of like how we sold
that in terms of like the autonomous
side of things is people are working
internally uh or like on their local
machines and things like that and that's
obviously not analytics best practice so
we want to move to a more complex cloud
computing kind of approach and that also
in terms of like making the business
case for things like that that helped
Shore up our digital like security
um so making the case that we can have a
One-Stop shop that supports both R and
pi python users in a secure Cloud
environment where they get to use the
tools that they like you're not you know
forcing python users to use our studio
or you're not forcing our studio users
to use vs code like everyone gets their
cake and gets to eat it too I'm terrible
at like these kind of phrases but
um yeah I think that was a big big part
of that I think it remains to be seen
right where kind of have a small like
developer license group initially
because we run we need to prove that
value first
um so that's kind of a big part of that
so I think once people start to see us
producing value and and centralizing on
this tool
um that will help us make the case to
expand the developer community on posit
um I'm also you know we're in the early
stages of developing like there's the
app that I'm working on but a lot of the
logic that exists in that app we're
trying to move into because it's pulling
directly from our database and doing
doing some standard analyzes we're we're
trying to move that into an internal
package so I think once there's like a
lining on the tools but then there's
also a lining on the code and the
workflows
um so I think internal package
development is a great inroad to not
only proving the the tools value but
also aligning people on how we work with
data because here I am going to be like
fangirling over Emily Ryder again but
she just recently put out a great blog
post that really laid out the
differences between SQL R and and both
uh pandas and numpy in Python and how
they handle nulls differently and how
this leads to completely different
results sometimes so I think it's really
important to align on workflows in
addition to aligning on tools but I
think that those tools enable the like
workflow centralization as well if that
makes sense
for sure yeah thanks it I really like
hearing the sort of stories in this
moment of adoption and then figuring out
how to go further and what those cases
are like and what those team processes
are like so
um yeah happy you had success and and uh
hopefully there's more in there I can
learn from thanks yeah thank you
and thank you
um so a question I remember we used to
always ask us in the beginning
um but what is something that you're
most excited about in the year ahead
when you think about your your data team
oh
well
um
I'm I wonder if she's listening on this
call but we recently so one of my like
my best work friend from a different
part of the organization recently
transferred onto our team so that we
could work more closely together and we
are building out this internal uh data
processing package and kind of trying to
develop some onboarding materials for
posits so I feel a little like imposter
syndrome and being like we're successful
with posit already because we're like
just at the beginning stages and have so
much more to learn
um so I'm most excited about like really
working
um with my friend to like build out uh
the onboarding for all of this to build
some shared workflows and then to kind
of socialize that more broadly in our
organization
um I think that will clearly demonstrate
the value of like why we invested in
these tools so it gets me excited to
think about people actually like you
using the apps we're developing people
being able to like easily access all of
the different reports like uh one of the
first projects we're planning on doing
once we get
um all of this like really up and
running and all the like deployment
issues kind of like ironed out is
building a central landing page like
from the posit like curating your data
science contact or content with uh
what's the connect widgets package
um which I'm so excited I I get really
excited about getting people to be able
to share their work more broadly more
seamlessly so there's so many like
really interesting reports and things
that people are doing at our
organization that often don't have the
kind of reach and impact that they could
if we just had a tool so that they could
easily like deploy it and just say like
here's a URL that shows all of the
reports that our team has done on this
specific topic and like you can just go
through and see like all of these
interesting Trends and and tools that
have been developed so I'm yeah I'm I'm
very very excited about like everything
that this new tooling will offer us and
just like building that workflow that
makes things really easy for people
yeah that's great I want to make sure
I'm not missing anybody's question so
feel free to raise your hand here on
Zoom or copy back over into the chat I
don't see too many over on slido
um
but Jared I think you had a question
earlier about GitHub actions do you want
to jump in yeah can you guys hear me
okay yes
yeah Natalie I just had a quick question
about your like internal checks that you
do for your programming like
applications and if you have them in
sort of like an automatic fashion or is
this something that you essentially from
the ground up trying to build in checks
as you go along to ensure consist not
only consistency but Integrity of the
data so you're not trying to put so many
fires out that it becomes insurmountable
if that makes sense oh yeah 100
uh man I feel like I'm just like beating
this drum of the Rhino framework but
um I didn't I'm still fairly new to
continuous integration I've done done a
little bit of like Ci CD stuff with um
Power bi before this but this is my
first time deploying a shiny app with
with continuous integration and and I I
did not develop it from the ground up
that was one of I I really loved the
Rhino package because it forces you into
some best practices and that's one of
the things that it forces you into
since deploying the app with that
framework I have learned a little bit
more about GitHub actions and have
modified
um that template you must best practice
Tatsu
um yeah so like for instance the um the
framework the way the the GitHub action
is set up it it runs a series of
different tests on every push and I've
realized oh my God like this is just
like every time I post a change to the
app it's running these continuous
integration tests and it's just like
overwhelming so I realized oh I just
need to change the yaml header and I can
make it so that it's only on pull
request that it runs these checks so uh
things like that so that was kind of
like
a design thing that was built into the r
or Rhino package that forced me to learn
something that I should have been doing
the whole time which but you know I I
I'm in a weird position now where I'm
like starting to become like more
recognized as like a shiny developer my
organization people are like coming to
me for advice and I always tell them
like I'm giving you this advice because
I've made this mistake 10 billion times
before and it's painful so when I'm
telling you like it's worth learning uh
shiny modules it's because I've built 10
billion shiny Frankenstein apps that
like quickly grow in complexity and then
are horrible to debug and and all of
these things so yeah that's a
long-winded explanation but again
plugging the the Rhino framework for
forcing me to learn about
um GitHub actions
um and and then the things that I didn't
like about the like default settings
that that helped me learn about GitHub
actions because then I needed to learn
how to like modify those settings so I'm
running linters
um you know yeah again like setting up
some deployment I don't even fully
understand how it's testing the runs on
Linux and and R and everything or Linux
and mac and all of these different
setups but to the vein of like building
relationships the fact that I had that
in my application made the data Ops Team
take me more seriously and they were
more willing to support my efforts to
get this tooling and to get it built out
because they saw oh you're not just like
ragtag shiny apps that like can never go
anywhere you're like building in more
robust ways and therefore I'm willing to
put in the time and effort to support
um support you because why would you you
know spend all this time and effort
you know Docker or not not dark but like
putting in uh building an entire
infrastructure in kubernetes if the
person that you're trying to help isn't
even like building something in a way
that can be maintained so I'm I'm the
big proponent of like meet your
engineers halfway and you'll have a lot
more success so where and when possible
you know really really try and
demonstrate some robust engineering
practices
awesome honest I see you have your hand
raised you want to jump in yes thank you
uh Natalie so
um our team has recently expanded we're
not a big team but on three or four
people that uh use our
um
obviously we're not Advanced enough to
get into the shinies but just broadly do
you have any tips on the best ways to
kind of establish best practices we're
again we're in our infancy we're more
like do we store these R scripts and our
network drive or in a SharePoint like
just in general we're trying to come up
with some procedures and standards and I
it feels like you've you've done that
before you've been there
I I've been there I am there yeah it's
uh I I would say like
again the Anthropologist in me is coming
out but like focus on relationships
first
um because inevitably like what you
define as a best practice on first case
like you're not going to be doing that
best practice like six months not always
right like there's certain things that
will stay and like teaching your team to
like use get branches and merge into
Maine and like some those things are
going to be pretty stable but like
there's other more thorny questions that
are really hard to build best practices
around so for example in our team we
have a lot we support a lot of different
uh organizations right with different
data analyzes and like how do we like
what size of repo do we put everything
into one big GitHub repo or do we make a
repo for every Organization for every
project like it's always in development
and it's constantly iterating so being
comfortable with that I think is a key
part of developing best practices
because it's never going to be just like
a set it and forget it best practice
it's going to be constant currently in a
relationship and you know Building
Together those best practices
um I find like we run in our users
office hours every two weeks
um and I often don't have an agenda or
anything and it's a great way to just
like first and foremost build community
but that's also where people come to say
like I'm really struggling with this
like how do you approach this and then
now we're starting to build those best
practices and as we build out the whole
kind of posit onboarding infrastructure
our hope is that we end like internal
packages like I think
building that into like vignettes right
or like Confluence document state I
haven't tried this out yet but I did see
that Corto is supporting like Confluence
documentation which is awesome because
our team uses Confluence pretty
significantly but I God I I hate
anything that's not like programmatic so
I want to have it as a script and R and
like I can automate or like I can get an
r and like alter that script but then
like send those updates so yeah maybe
not the best answer but um just be
comfortable with iterating and like make
sure that you're always communicating
with each other and building strong
relationships
yeah that was wonderful thank you
I think that focus on relationships
just want to jump in
yeah I was just wondering um you
mentioned some of the reporting that
you're doing out of shiny so are you
also in addition to work Venture using
uh connect
yes yeah so the app will be deployed on
connect and then we do a ton of ad hoc
reporting
um which again right now is kind of like
here's uh a Google spreadsheet with like
the answers to your question or here's
like at most like a PDF of uh our
markdown report but hopefully once we
have like the whole infrastructure
running that will all live in a landing
page that's continuously updated again
my focus on like parameterizing
everything but using the pins package
right to like add metadata to whatever
you're deploying whether it's a report
an app or anything and then having that
all land in a central page
um yeah I think that's it that's a big
one of the big benefits of the whole
like posit infrastructure
absolutely we talked about pins last
week I think right yeah good to hear
absolutely thanks lots of love for pins
um I see Jared you had asked a question
on recommendations you want to jump in
sure I think I asked this about every
every talk but any books that you
recommend Natalie that you have read
that would be of use to this group I
guess
yeah I saw Curtis recommended the
engineering production grade shiny apps
so that is definitely a great one
um I find I'm well I wouldn't say I'm
not a book learner like I've gone
through like the r packages book and
took pretty detailed notes on that
um so all of like the I feel like
there's like an R Cannon which is like R
for data science first and foremost then
you've got like Advanced R and you know
uh R packages and those things so those
are always like great references
um but I'm the kind of person that tends
to learn a lot from
um like tutorials and things so again
I'm bringing up the Rhino framework just
because I love it so much
um and I I basically learned that just
by going through their tutorial
um and then there's obviously people
within the r community that I follow
their blogs and and learn a lot from
them so
um the system I developed for this
reporting system is heavily so it's like
built in the Rhino framework but it
borrows heavily from G1 uh heo I think
is how you pronounce his last name
um but he he put out a blog post on
using our six classes and gargoyle
triggers to kind of like manage
reactivity within your app and I wanted
to make sure that my that people weren't
like accidentally running a ton of
database queries so I built the system
in a way
um to like when someone kind of selects
their filters they select their filters
they click the action button it runs a
DB plier query it saves the results of
that to an R6 object that I then pass
around to different modules to build
visualizations run analyzes whatever and
then like populate slide decks by
transferring it to the Google API so
there's like a whole slew um slew of
things there yeah
they answer your question I feel like I
lost track of your original question
their apologies if I no that's that's
great I uh in terms of books if also if
there's anyone that you follow
um like social media wise that you feel
like it's been a big influence on how
you've done your work yeah essentially
helping you know the muses and mentors
that you feel like you've uh you've
gathered or garnered
yeah so Emily Ryder
big fan she'll be on here next week
um Maya Gans for shining app development
huge influence awesome person too
um who giwand Hyo I I really loved his
blog post on our six classes and and
gargoyle triggers I thought it was a
really clever approach and completely
stole it for my own work
um but that's the benefit right still
like an artist that was the that's the
name of the talk that uh Sharla
anejamaka are doing it pause it
um trying to think I'm sure I'm missing
other people that are huge influences
um I mean obviously like all the people
from posit you know Hadley but uh and
then like Jenny Bryan right I I the
amount of times that I have sent around
her thing of like if you set if your
script starts with set working directory
I will come into your office and set
your computer on fire
I use that a lot so
uh yeah so lots of influences there's
just such an amazing community of our
users and that's what made me want to
continue down this whole career path
I love it I know we talked a bit about
like building a business case in the
beginning and we were just talking about
this internally like is there a way that
I could make like
this tool or calculator for people and I
was just wondering like in building a
business case did you actually have to
put like a monetary value to like what
you would provide or like saving money
for automations I don't know just
curious yes for sure and I'll answer
that I just wanted to someone mentioned
like integrating design thinking and
data science and I just another like
influence of mine that's like a blog
post course whatever person is um Brian
O'Neal he does a lot of like designing
human-centered data products so I'll
just plug his work as also being a
really big influence in someone you
should check out if you want to build
tools that people actually use which I
hope we all do
um but yeah for as far as putting a like
number on what we would be offering we
again I have the world's best manager I
could not go on about that anymore he's
wonderful
um and much more business savvy than I
am so he helped set me up with the team
we did kind of like a whole so
um
Prof or like a what's the now I'm forget
because I'm not the business person but
um we we did kind of survey people in
terms of like how much time are you
spending building a single slide deck
like where are all the places that you
have to go like on average you spend say
10 hours building this slide deck
um and then hey if all of these data
points were populated automatically for
you how much would how much time would
be remaining so we kind of used that and
then obviously like factoring in
people's salaries and all these things
and then came up with like a rough
estimate of the the time cost savings
um that building now this app would
would have so and you know and building
oh this is kind of another like good
piece of advice is like
the app I've built now like I don't
think anyone would have been able to see
that if I just like started with that
like building mves or MVP you know like
little little pieces of the pie like I
started off doing parameterized
reporting with our markdown and people
were like that's amazing
um and but the problem with that is that
I can't quite you know people aren't
going to have the kind of flexibility on
the end so I'm like this is great this
is how we actually like populate slide
decks with with Data Insights but if you
want the flexibility to
change The Branding alter the wording
all of this stuff like this is our next
MVP and then you just kind of like work
your way up to like now I have a
production grade shiny app that does all
of this for you
um but always kind of like building in
little chunks that get you there
that's incredibly helpful thank you I I
know that people are doing this but I
never know like exactly how you do it so
that's cool that you like hold everybody
and ask how much time they were spending
doing something
um I these are the fastest hours of the
week so I know when we're coming to the
end here
um but a question I've recently started
asking that I I really like is
um what's the best sorry not best well
what's the piece of advice that comes to
mind to you that you've either given to
somebody on your team or that you've
received uh over the course of your
career
could be the best piece or just whatever
comes to mind
I don't think I follow this as much as I
should because I let my enthusiasm get
the best of me but my manager is always
giving me the advice that is very well
given which is uh under promise over
deliver like it's classic advice but
like that is what you need to be doing
so like
I get so excited about building the
community around stuff that I'm like
look guys this is this is what I did
today and like I want to grab them and
be like how can you use it and do all
that but like oftentimes it's better to
just like put some breaks on and say
like I'm gonna like make sure I get this
like really ironed out I document how I
did it I do you know whatever you need
so that it's not just like hey like
watch me program this and like build it
up like that's fine I do a lot of pair
programming with people but if you can
kind of like get something like real
nice and streamlined and like
professional looking before like showing
everybody that's kind of the way to go
so under promise over deliver best
advice that I often don't follow
I feel the exact same all right
president was just telling me earlier
today to focus on a few important things
instead of all of these important things
let me just double check I want to check
on some of the questions if I missed
anything so feel free to put it back
into the chat or or raise your hand here
um but I think it's so cool that your
team does the office hours and you have
this community group too
um and I was just wondering a little bit
more about like what the office hours
look like so if somebody wanted to start
that at their team like is it virtual is
it an hour
yeah so we do one hour every two weeks
um and we I think it's it's hard like
we've kind of ended up at this right now
um just doing like informal Gathering so
like I'm there for the hour whoever like
stops in if you have any questions again
just trying to like make sure people
know that there are no stupid questions
like not being judgmental like if you're
like struggling with something that like
I can spot the issue in two seconds not
being like why don't you understand this
you don't know how to use the command
line well like whatever it doesn't
matter just like hey we solved a problem
together this is exciting this was fun
um and so that gets people to like want
to come back and bring their questions
and all those things right now we don't
have an agenda we are wanting to
hopefully move especially like now that
we're like really starting to iron out
all of the installation stuff with posit
um we're hoping to use those office
hours as a time for onboard people into
that system so
um hoping to do like a little workshop
series on like using git and GitHub
within posit and you know how to deploy
something onto connect and so
um I think that will give us like a
really nice kind of series of things to
go through but it can be hard because
people have like they're jobs that they
need to do and so building Community is
just kind of one of those things I talk
to like my better up coach all the time
about like that's just how I approach my
work no matter whether you pay me to or
not like I'm gonna try and build a
community like that's what I'm gonna do
yeah
I just thank you I'd like to jump in
because I yeah we we have an office
hours set up as well
um and we actually ended up kind of
divorcing the office hours from the how
to's and the onboarding things because
we ended up you know the interest in
those has kind of a season and so we
would have like okay here's what we're
going to talk about in this week's like
our user group as opposed to like the
our office hours where people are
bringing those more ad hoc questions but
definitely as we were building up to
that it was just kind of one meeting and
then we found okay we do the office
hours once a month and the user group
once a month but on opposite every two
weeks kind of thing so it's like still
the two-week timeline but different
Focus
um
yeah I think that I might have to take
that advice to heart I like that yeah
yeah it's really nice to have well I
always think about that because of the
Hangouts too it is nice having the like
informal session where anything can come
up as well
absolutely that's great well thank you
thank you so much Natalie for for
joining and sharing your experience with
us if people want to get in touch with
you as LinkedIn the best way or yeah
yeah so you can get a hold of me on
LinkedIn I do still have a Twitter but I
haven't really checked it since the like
forceful takeover that you all know what
I'm talking about
um haven't been as active on Mastodon
but I'm also on there
um so yeah happy to chat thank you
awesome and I want to make sure I share
the data science by Design too I was
gonna I could share these links with the
recording too
please yeah definitely
um check out our new Anthology series
it's going to be it's going to be great
awesome thank you so much have a great
rest of the day everybody nice to see
you